I'm actually embarrassed by this title
it's it's certainly bombastic but then
again you know we The Economist has a
cover this is that we live in a post
truth era so it might be more
appropriate paper about the provenance
of [ __ ] but I'm not an expert I mean
I'm just the occasional user so let's
see what we can say about precise things
I I'd like to point out that this at
least the form of this presentation
comes out of work that I did here and
they match the influence of very cradle
with my work but it follows some work
with a lot of people that was in the
real mo of database theory but I hope
that today's presentation will be which
is geared toward logicians will not
necessarily need motivation from
database theory I hope so the truth in
the title of my talk is not about
validity that's you know mark it's just
truth of model checking and in fact as
you shall see truth of model checking in
finite models so consider you know if I
model here and the way we think of it
here is that some sort of collection of
information items by which I mean both
let's say relational facts and absence
of relational facts negations they're
off and then we have a sentence fee in
this sentence in this model may end up
being true or made up being false and
our interest is in seeing how that
happened so again from the motivation in
database theory we think of we use this
word provenance to understand to
actually make this question how that
happened a little bit more precise so
people can and did look at questions
such as which information items in the
we'll made the sentence to are used in
the checking that's really boring but
more general question is why did it so
happen and and the reason this is more
interesting is because there may be
alternative reasons why the sentence
ends up through in this model and these
alternative reasons can be exploited as
we shall see and what I will actually
show is sort of a very general
provenance analysis of truth which
answers the question how is the model
information how is it really used to
check on the truth of fee and we shall
see this a little bit more clearly so
the first thing we need to do is I and I
should apologize for the low quality of
my slides because this was put together
rather quickly it's basically a latex to
powerpoint I'm sorry so the the idea is
that when you actually evaluate or
determine check a sentence in a model
there are two different ways of using
the information to establish the truth
of that sentence there are joint ways
and alternative ways and the joint ways
for example come into play in reasoning
about conjunction or universal
quantifications truth alternative ways
disjunction and existential
quantification and the idea is that we
are going to consider non-logical
non-standard interpretations of these
concepts in some sort of algebraic
structure in which we have two binary
operations one which we denote with dot
and the other one with plus that roughly
correspond to these two different ways
of understanding and using information
and to us to see how different this is
from the usual logical reasoning think
for example that you want to do you want
to cost the truth of this of the center
so you are adding costs whenever you use
information jointly but then
you know you're mean you're choosing the
minimum cost when you have alternatives
it's one way and in fact it will
correspond something that we use so
notice then then so these are is you
recognize the usual transformations that
we use it for for putting a sentence in
pre next normal form so the first two
are not at all clearly holding so look
at this for all X fee and see so what
may happen is that i will have some cost
of establishing c and separately some
cost of establishing fee for all the
exes that I care about but then if i
write it like this then the cost of
establishing c is repeated in fact for
every x even though x does not care
there but it's not relevant similarly
this one is also arguing in the same way
not necessarily in equality with
existential quantifiers there is this
particular transformation from exists x
fee or c to exist X Y Z and this one can
be thought of as holding but if you
think about it just just because minimum
is idempotent because you still actually
repeat potentially the cost of a well
when you want to establish an extension
quantify you just need to do it once
right and here of course you may end up
repeating the the cost of C but because
mean is that important doesn't matter on
the other hand in all the
interpretations that that I could think
about this one particular transformation
does hold namely pulling an existential
out of a conjunction it's possible and
Steve a table whether that there will be
interesting interpretation which days
and hold but for the moment that's not
the case so if you think about all these
things hard what you end up with is a
lunch break
actually corresponds to what's called
the commutative semi ring and that's the
our non standard interpretation domain
for for logic that we shall play with so
k + x 0 and 1 so there are interesting
commutative sim earrings in which we can
actually say things about logical truth
again in interesting ways so just a bit
of terminology we say that the
committing its community when
multiplication is commutative but we say
that it is idempotent when audition is
idempotent that's just tradition in that
area of course the bullion's are the
basic commutative simmering natural
numbers are a community of simmering
this one is of great interest in in
what's called back semantics in
databases but I shall not get into that
today this is estimating that these two
say meanings which is morphic I will
talk about and they are well-known to
many people in the audience so this one
is let's say thinking about the cost
that I mentioned on the previous slide
it's called the tropical simmering for
for bizarre reasons and here the plus is
men and the x is plus so you have to
keep your things straight as you say
reason about this tropical same inning
but it is it may be easier to sometimes
to think in its I so morph which is
called the Viterbi say meeting because
this something like this was used in
certain dime a dynamic programming
algorithms in reasoning about decoding
and so on by Viterbi so in determining
for instance path of maximum likelihood
so the times that you see here is about
multiplying probabilities because there
are some independence assumptions and
the max is about finding the path of
maximum probability but the way I will
think about this emitting is all these
numbers are confidence coefficients
confidence scores and the higher the
closer to 1 the higher the confidence I
can have in this
and the two are actualized morphic so
here I can think about the cost as the
cost of screwing it up so the higher the
cost of screwing it up the the less
confidence it means you have in the in
the in that particular fact this one is
the distributive lattice all
distributive lattices are in fact of
course commutative same earrings but
this one is just a very simple one it
has five elements i order them like this
and i take min and Max and this one
let's call it access control if you
think of these things as levels of
access control such as public
confidential secret top secret and
there's one at the very top so secret
that nobody can access it so we don't
know about that stuff it's not there
then then this would allow us to reason
about access control and I shall have at
the end an example there's been a lot of
mathematics called fuzzy mathematics
that's been done in this simmering I
don't have anything special to say about
it but here is a really really
interesting simmering in which we shall
actually do a lot of reasoning about
provenance and as the same inning of
polynomials the coefficients are natural
numbers the rest is just plus x usual
and the polynomials have multi their
multivariate polynomials the intel intel
indeterminate are from some set X and I
shall think of this set X as labels or
in fact a technology like is tokens that
I attached I annotate two facts of
interest and then I use these tokens and
what happens to them to track the
provenance of those facts of interest
through the model checking and it's both
ways the commutative say meaning freely
generated by the set X and that's going
to be used in there in the good
composition on a categorical way that
that we the only way we know how to do
things right and another one is boolean
expressions this one by the way I should
recall
the talks about probabilistic databases
are used under the name lineage in
trying to compute probability for
queries all right so let's do something
different now so suppose we have a fine
relation of vocabulary and we have a
finite set of ground values and not yet
a model so I'm going to do I'm going to
talk about sentences without having a
model it's a little weird but I'm you
will see what the benefit of doing that
will be so let's denote by facts the set
of all ground relational atoms for with
our from this vocabulary and this is
some vector of ground values and let's
denote with negative facts you know the
negated facts and as we using logic
programming let's call the union of
these two literals so these are those
information items in the model that I
care about and I'm going to as you shall
see eventually label them annotate them
with these provenance tokens and see
what happens in the truth of a saying
the checking of the center's now an
interpretation for a semi ring k a
commutative say meeting k or and the
technology i'll use a que interpretation
is absolutely simply a mapping from the
literals to k so I'm just associating to
every literal an element of the same
eating whether provenance or cost or
confidence or access control whatever
all those things will be things we can
exploit but I shall say like right now
that very roughly the idea is that the
zero of the semi ring is going to be
used to interpret things that end up
being irredeemably false and not 0
things that will be true and now notice
that we have a lot more nuance in the
interpretation of truth because there
will be cursing the boolean simmering
there's only one thing that's not 0
that's true but in all these other same
earrings we have a lot of new and
interpreting truth at various other
elements in the same inning and let's
see what that gives so this this first
thing that we can say is that let's say
that that an interpretation is
consistent if the product of the
interpretation of fact and its negation
is 0 the same earrings in which all the
same meanings which I showed the
beginning have a property it's called
positivity and the same meaning is
positive it's I if it satisfies these
two properties a times B 0 that means
that either a or Z or b is 0 + a + b 0
that means both are 0 it's sort of think
natural numbers and it turns out all the
same earrings that I've shown earlier
are positive some innings which are not
positive are basically rings like the
integers or the integers you know mod to
the boolean ring and but it's not clear
what the interpretation in those
particular see meanings would give us
and so I have nothing intelligent to say
for the moment but who knows so in a
positive semi ring when I say the
interpretation is consistent one of
these two must be 0 so that's good i'm
not going to make both of them
potentially true and well this is a
little ambitious to call this complete
but you know that's what the terminology
is in logical theories so we say the
interpretation is complete if their sum
is not 0 so that means that they can't
both be 0 and in fact if we take this
interpretation we can now extend it to
all parts of the logic formula in the
obvious way of course for the literals
in the way that I hinted at for the
conjunction is multiplication this
Junction is addition existential is just
finite sums so it's not clear what this
all means outside of a fight model but
who knows
our meetings in which infinite sums
exist and for universal quantification
it's a product and this is the trick
that Eric really I had a lot of trouble
with negation and then those of you who
were at my first talk in August recall
that I was just throwing my hands up but
Eric actually helped me see the light
and his suggestion was well let's look
at my geisha normal form so that's kind
of punting on the issue right
interpreting negation or subtraction in
general commutative same innings in
other words finding an operation in the
semi ring yeah not plus or times yet a
third unary operation that somehow
captures the idea of negation is hard so
I mean of course in the in boolean
algebra as we have but for natural
numbers what is it there is something
called moon whose and so there is no
nice theory and there are multiple
divergent ways of dealing with this and
in very annoying so negation normal form
actually allows us to essentially punt
on this that this is a term from
American football but in terms of
European and other you know football for
the rest of the religious means to clear
a ball from your from your box of 18 and
get it out of there so now things
actually become very nice so look at
this well the interpretation of double
negation is the same and the Morgan as
well you know so negation stops being a
problem so we can focus on the
difference between conjunction and
disjunction so the first thing we can do
since I talked about consistency and
completeness is to say well if K is
positive then consisting completeness
lift to entire formulate sentences is
like a basic sanity check so in a
positive semi ring if the original
interpretation of the literals is
consistent and complete then you look at
the interpretation of some formula fee
and its negation and you just know that
one of those
is different from zero and the other one
is zero society to check number one and
sign check number two is well considered
a model and there is a canonical
interpretation of course for that model
namely the literals which are true in
the model are going to be talked through
in false and then the model checks that
sentence if and only if the
interpretation gives us through so so
there's nothing bizarre here it starts
from stuff that we understand but where
does it go and this is where it becomes
so much more interesting so I'm going to
build a simmering in which we can talk
about provenance whatever we shall see
that means so the provenance token some
set of provenance tokens X because I
want to deal with both positive and
negative facts it helps actually to make
a copy of it so so X and X bar are going
to be disjoint sets but in by jection so
i'm going to use P for Providence token
for a PO for a fact and P bar for that
same fact negated and I'll better make
sure that not both of them are at the
same time nonzero right okay and what i
can do is i take that same meaning of
polynomials and I can quotient by all
these equalities P times P bar equals 0
for all the peas in X and the result is
essentially the set of polynomials in
which in no monomial do we have both a
pee and a P bar but a p and a P bar may
occur in different monomials of the
polynomial so with this let's spend some
time I mean on an example I think this
is where we can understand best what's
going on so here is a sentence that says
that in a graph the vertex X is is I
just made this up is dominant I don't
think that people use this terminology
but I need a simple example so what does
that mean for any other vertex either
it's the
aim or for any other vertex there is an
edge from X to Y but there is no edge
from Y to X so these dominant princesses
have edges to everybody else but nobody
has an edge to them it's not an
unreasonable name notice I skipped over
this but notice that we can throw into
this logic easily equality and
inequality it's just not a problem the
interpretation of these things will
always be 0 or 1 so a moment just just
take a moment to describe the
interpretation or what 0 and 1 means so
0 means it's not there doesn't exist you
know false blah blah blah but one is
more interesting one is the from a
provenance perspective one is the
interpretation of a fact that i want to
take for granted that comes for free
that I choose not to track whenever I
need to use it I can use it and and it's
just not something that will affect my
my otherwise analysis of provenance so
that's the meaning of what okay so then
I take the sentence that just for fun
you know I I'll consider also its
negation for all X there is not there's
no dominant vertex and these examples
can get pretty big so I'm just going to
consider a very small set of three
ground value so this is about grass with
just three vertices and I'm going to use
some provenance tokens and remember the
provenance tokens will be for facts like
e of say a and B and therefore they are
going to be for the presence of some
edges this one's and this one's for the
absence of some edges but i'll use the
word potential here because in this
provenance analysis i will actually
track both and then i'll make sure that
i'll never actually assume both the
presence and the absence of the same
edge
so you know this example it's always
better think of it graphically to ignore
all that stuff so look at this
particular set of edges / ABC so here
for this edge which is the edge from B
to a I'm going to use the program's
token tea for its potential presence
empty bar for its potential absence and
so on these ones which are dashed notice
that there's a0 and a1 so the these are
the edges which for sure are absent so
the provenance of their presence is 0
and the provenance of their absence is
one and I thought I should end there
others which I am NOT drawing here ok
and this is now an interpretation in
that particular say meeting that I just
discussed earlier in which I just attach
two literals PP bar as we discussed and
everybody else 0 for all the other
positive facts and one for all the other
negative facts so the calculation that I
can do now in this simmering of the
provenance of that particular sentence
fee which says for all X not dominant of
X is the following so first I put in
negation or more for encodes the same
thing and then you just you have to
trust me we don't have time to do so go
through this you just get to this three
polynomials multiplied I'm not going to
multiply these three because you know
there's a lot of stuff coming out but so
notice that whenever i multiply P bar
with speed that that monomer is going to
go away because P times u bar is 0 so
there should be if I counted correctly
34 monomials in in this provenance and
and I call such polynomial one version
of what we could call provenance right
what does it mean well let's look at a
couple of the monomial
so SD is somewhere in there p bar cube
RR is somewhere in there after
multiplication so recall now that s T is
actually saying there's an edge from s
as an edge from C to B this one and
teach as an edge from B to a so I can
think of these the presence of these
edges as denying the dominance right so
this one denies the dominance will be
this one denies the dominance of a so
just knowing that that the dominance of
a and B is denied is it should be enough
for me to prove that there is no
dominant vertex you may ask well how
about see it turns out that the
dominance of C comes the non dominance
of C comes for free why because I know
there is no edge from Sittwe that's
assumed so what's really important is
that this thing here is a bunch of
tracking provenance assumptions that you
make at the very beginning so under
these assumptions we can do a certain
amount of reasoning if you need to to
reason about things which are not
captured by these assumptions then you
need to change these assumptions so
that's that the limitation of the
framework so for this one I actually
drew for you a proof three we're not
going to try to decode it we don't have
time so this is the proof tree that
there is no vertex dominant that's a lot
of abbreviations here that uses the fact
that well there is no vertex from A to B
there's no vertex from B to C and there
is one from C to a so this one denies
the dominance of a this one denies the
dominance will be and this one denies
the dominance of C which gives you this
proof three so in fact the provenance
polynomial just showing you actually
counts all the proof trees and there are
34 of them so one way
and describes them too so one way to and
and I shall also hope that you believe
yeah so each monomial corresponds with
distinct proof three okay so if you are
interested in how many ways you can
check this thing in exactly thirty four
ways well the polynomial that I have
there is not so interesting but you can
get things like coefficients of more
than one is an example an even exponent
which I will I will skip and let me also
compute the provenance because I heine
for an example of the negation of that
same sentence namely there exists a
dominant vertex this one is a lot
simpler it just has two monomials and
only two ways to prove that that that in
fact there exists a dominant vertex this
one makes a dominant the vertex a this
one makes a vertex be dominant there is
no way to make vertex Adomian under
those tracking assumptions so how hard
this computer's provenances some cheap
complexity remarks the province
expressions have have size number of
ground values at the size of the formula
but if you put it in polynomial form is
like putting in normal forme boolean
expressions that may be exponential also
in a think this example however for the
database relevant things where you don't
have universal quantification to prove
something
but this this sentence is the negation
so this is the sentence that says
something is dominant and I have two
proofs of that except in each of the
proofs other vertices are dominant so in
the first proof p makes a dominant are
makes be dominant t-bar makes I know
it's more complicated than that p and t
bar are needed to make a dominant and
yeah so a is dominant in the second one
B is dominant yeah so in fact PR and key
bar are all needed to make a dominant I
think what the question really was this
you proved me two contradictory things
but you proved you them from publicly
hypotheses yes so these are two
different proofs the proof and it's just
yeah these are contradictory that's
right so that's sort of that's because
well so that's the nice thing an
interesting thing about this provenance
analysis like this is that I can't have
both P and P bar be true so in any given
model yes only one of these two
monomials is going to be realized
so and I think you can compute the
number of proof trees so finally what is
the the sanity check number three it's
right here so if K is positive and you
have what we call it and a
interpretation that's let's say truth
compatible with the model namely the
literals which are made through by the
model our map to something that's not 0
and those which are made false by the
model are mapped to 0 then you actually
get that the sentence is true in the
model if and only if it gets a nonzero
interpretation and that's in every so
it's like a cheap sort of science and
teacher the interesting thing is to
prove this actually we prove something
much more important which I dare call
the fundamental property which is right
here and I should have really put some
diagrams here so what is it it gives you
a comparison between run happens in two
different same earrings if you have a
homomorphism between them suppose you
have homomorphism suppose you have two
interpretations related by their
homomorphism then any sentence when you
interpret it in the two different sim
earrings will be related by the same
homomorphism and in fact well I'm going
to skip this because I don't have time
but what you have here is a proof using
this of that scientific number three you
see it's like you're your baseline truth
yes right that in itself I don't know
how to use but I the hormone murphy's I
I mean the whole morphism itself that
takes me there I i use right so I know
I'm overtime you're being very patient
so confidence maximization and then
something about access controls because
it really this is this is where we get
mileage out of this so let's look at the
negation I had two sentences fine not
fine let's look at this one and let's
try to interpret
in the Viterbi same earring suppose that
I map absolutely every provenance
talking to one half that corresponds to
actually assuming some you know for lack
of a better a confidence of one half for
all my facts I know this is not
consistent yeah because I'm mapping both
P and P bar I know this is not
consistent but I'm going to be saved by
the inconsistency from the fact that I'm
looking only a distinct monomials and in
any monomial by my construction there
will be no inconsistency because there
will be no monomial in which both P and
P bar can occur so then if i look at
this proof and at this provenance and
interpret it and the whole point of the
fundamental properties that you can do
the provenance in general then you can
interpret it in various particular sim
earrings and in this case in the
confidence a meaning you notice that
this one has better confidence in that
18 or one sixteenth and in fact that
what that means is that i can construct
a model in which i can maximize the
confidence and here it is the model and
the big dashes mean that these edges
cannot be present our option and the
small dashes means that it doesn't
matter so is actually a whole family of
models in which the confidence is
maximized so that's one of the things
you can do with provenance analysis and
interpretation inside the Viterbi same
inning another example is this access
control so therefore this one actually
took the fee not the not fee so suppose
we know that these two tokens are our
public so its public that there is an
edge from A to B but and public that
there is no edge from C to a and so on
but SNT are top secret so now if you
calculate the meaning in this same
waiting for the sentence you get that
yeah it's true and this through this
public but assuming the provenance
analysis allows you to say more because
you can look around in this polynomial
and and both of them are going to be
alternate corresponding to alternative
proofs and in fact this one is going to
be this monomial itself is going to be
top secret this one is going to be
public so yeah it's true and most people
will know that it is true because p and
r bar but those will stop secret
clearance okay I'm really in the realm
of BS here those who is top secret
clearance will know that there is an
alternative program may be that useful
because maybe there's more confidence in
that okay that's what we want to do with
all this stuff there's a lot more and
I'm already over time an interesting
problem is maximizing confidence not in
one model which can be done sort of
locally but maxy are there ways in which
we can maximize confidence in all models
and can this be done for and in fact for
the fragment of facade illogic
corresponding to positive existential
existential conjunctive also known as
conjunctive queries this is in fact done
by what's known as take going to the
core that's good not surprisingly but
that's if and only if the same eating
has this property which is called
absorption and there's much more to be
say about that there's a lot which I
mentioned in my first talkie in August
but I don't have time to mention now
when you add to the positive fragment
least for these fixed points and there
are some interesting connections that I
hope to explore most dramatically is to
at least fix points to the whole force
of the logic and potentially other
logics like mu calculi etcetera and
there are some interesting connections
with context-free grammars but not for
visual languages but for languages of
commutative words what's a commutative
word at the bag so the order of the
letter doesn't matter so I'm sorry for
running over
questions this self constraint
satisfaction to say that there is a
property which is very important which
is there the importancy of the
multiplicative ovulation because without
that you cannot make petrification this
property is a measurement in this
setting is not so I do you mean I'd
importance of the Aditi additionally so
for example when you talk about cost
what corresponds to multiplication is
adding costs and you know it just
doesn't make it's not that interesting
to add costs and to say that 10 plus 10
is 10 yeah yeah so so so of course this
framework is general and the examples
you describe our particular cases but
the examples I found interesting from
the database provenance and from what I
talked about today do not have that
particular I mean for in the access
control say meaning for example in all
these two beauty lattices this is the
case yes I should say and I wanted to
say that you know a lot of work with say
meetings has been done in the context of
soft constraint satisfaction problems by
mr. le and montanari
not good okay so just to make her about
to connect the Providence entering work
with other things might seem surprising
so really presented a resource algebra
which was a full context chew ality now
the that was done with respect to
probability distributions but one can
generalize that that's business of
something we've a useful generalization
to any communities right the operations
that would look like sort of a static
part of the process algebra essentially
the relational algebra version of the
day of the standard database really
language over in this semi ring
provident sense there's a rather direct
connection so it's a way of doing
resource analysis of normal logic
without going to linear logic I don't
think those are connected the video
lottery I was just you know it's cuz I
was a this was drummed into my head for
the last 25 years that you know if you
want to analyze the resource usage
linear logic I think about the fog on
rather making isn't there's a connection
with things motivated buyers I
compliment as quite as hope this dorama
psi I the operations of her eyes that
did not have time to look at that but I
very much look forward to you right
let's thankfully
[Applause]